on a bien fait les choses au mondial de
la cuisine dans leur petit périmètre
bien cloisonner les chefs dispose de
toute leur panoplie personnel pour
mitonner les plats de la consécration
les produits sont imposés les recettes
sont libres exemple le thème de la
demi-finale avait pour sujet un saumon
de 3 kg avec 4 garniture préparations
chaudes pour 8 personnes et le temps
d'exécution de cette petite merveille
quatre heures montre en main le
sélectionner français jacky frais on est
un jeune chef talentueux de l'hôtel
lutetia concorde entre deux préparations
et sans la moindre pause
il nous a confié son opinion
ça crée une émulation parmi xie d'un
monde entier et ça ne peut être que
favorable pour toutes les cuisines
comment les i comment les étrangers
jugent notre cuisine d'après vous elle
est au top niveau là
je connais dans les dents les premières
que c'est une mode
il est bien évident qu'un juge suivant
s'apprendre sensibilité ses propres
goûts vous ça face à quelque chose de
subjectif qui s'appelle le goût et c'est
extrêmement difficile de pouvoir le
déterminer cette mesure grâce à ce c'est
très difficile à faire ressortir si vous
voulez
est ce qu'il ya à l'heure actuelle un
effort de formation à faire en france
enfin oui il ya toujours un effort de
formation à faire mais c'est bien
évident que sont depuis ces dix
dernières années il ya eu un effort
considérable dans l'apprentissage et la
formation professionnelle vous avez le
sentiment que les chefs français sont
assez nombreux pour bien représenter
notre cuisine leurs documents et le
valais qui se prépare ah oui absolument
pardon
oui absolument une relève qui se prépare
non seulement il ya une relève qui se
prépare mais disons que cette relève et
est aussi le relève des qualités et je
pense parce qu'il suffit pas d'avoir une
rolex est aussi qu'elle soit bonne
sézanne wever la seule femme de ce
mondial travaille actuellement au
ritz-carlton de chicago elle n'a pas
encore atteint le sommet de la
hiérarchie professionnelle que ça vous
fait ce métier c'est un métier ça
devrait passer
la banda s'est passionné pour ça vous
avez le rang de chef je crois par dont
vous êtes un chef à chiens son chef
les grands chefs à part entière pour
leur part sont réunies en un jury
international 2 sélections ctoc parmi
les plus étoilés note les candidats sur
un total de 40 points 20 pour la
dégustation aux 10 pour la présentation
et 10 pour l'originalité
les japonais sont de redoutables clients
ils ne feront pas de cadeau à ce mondial
le premier prix recevra s'il vous plaît
dix mille dollars avec en prime le
bocuse d'or réalisées par notre césar
national jean blanchet vous êtes un peu
monsieur cuisine française à chicago oui
on m'appelle le blocus de l'amérique et
j'ai un restaurant français dont les
américains apprécient depuis très
longtemps je suis ouvert depuis 12 ans
et je suis complet depuis 12 ans ça veut
dire que notre cuisine est très apprécié
et les apprécier elle sera toujours très
apprécié c'est la grande cuisine
rien est équivalent aux états unis les
américains apprennent avec vous beaucoup
beaucoup les américains prennent
beaucoup avec moi et après ou leur
restaurant tient mais malgré tout ils
n'arrivent pas encore à la hauteur des
pensées qu'est ce que vous reprochez aux
américains commercial tout tout est
commercial
j'aime l'argent et prend beaucoup
d'argent et plus intéressante que faire
une qualité
autrement dit l'assiette ne compte pas
tellement non il faut voir en bas
revenus financiers sacré américain
difficile de trouver une rime
gastronomique avec monnet une chose est
sûre le gotha de la cuisine
réunis à lyon médiatisé à souhait aura
sûrement des prolongements un ouvrage
traduit en trois langues est d'ores et
déjà prévu les droits d'auteur seront
versés aux chercheurs du sida la cuisine
c'est sa grande bea